I wanted to say a few words this morning about the passing of an extraordinary leader,...
...Senator Edward Kennedy.
Over the past several years, I've had the honor to call Teddy a colleague,...
...a counselor and a friend.
And even though we have known this day was coming for some time now,...
...we awaited it with no small amount of dread.
Since Teddy's diagnosis last year, we've seen the courage with which he battled his illness.
And while these months have no doubt been difficult for him,...
...they've also let him hear from people in every corner of our nation and from around the world,...
...just how much he meant to all of us.
His fight has given us the opportunity we were denied when his brothers John and Robert were taken from us.
The blessing of time to say thank you and goodbye.
The outpouring of love, gratitude and fond memories to which we've all borne witness...
...is a testament to the way this singular figure in American history touched so many lives.
His ideas and ideals are stamped on scores of laws and reflected in millions of lives.
In seniors who know new dignity.
In families that know new opportunity.
In children who know education's promise.
And in all who can pursue their dream in an America that is more equal and more just.
Including myself.